Last time, we were talking
about the energies of the
various states in the
multi-electron atom.
Now, the question is,
experimentally,
how do we know what these
energies are?
How do we know these energy
levels exist?
And the primary technique that
we have to know that is
something called X-ray
photoelectron spectroscopy.
And X-ray photoelectron
spectroscopy uses the same
principle that we talked about
when we talked about photo
emission or the photoelectric
effect really explained by
Einstein.
And, by the way,
I put on the website a very
comprehensible article on
Einstein's contribution to the
photoelectric effect.
This is something that just
came out in a journal just very
recently and I saw it.
And so I urge you to take a
look at it because it really is
very understandable and kind of
fills in some of the gaps that I
left in talking about the actual
problems, some of the kind of
sociological effects or gaps.
All right.
So same idea,
photoelectron spectroscopy and
that we come in with a photon
and that induced an electron to
be emitted.
But unlike the photoelectron
spectroscopy on a solid,
where we essentially had just
one energy level,
in photoelectron spectroscopy
on atoms we're going to have
many energy levels,
as we've already seen.
And the photon that we're going
to use, that photon is going to
have an energy so that in
principle it can pull out of the
atom the most strongly-bound
electron.
And if we want that,
well, then that means that
we're going to have to use a
pretty energetic photon and,
that is, we're going to use an
X-ray photon.
So it works in the following
way.
Let's take this unsuspecting
neon atom.
We bring in a photon,
an X-ray photon.
[LAUGHTER] I'll turn it down a
little bit.
Not too much.
And that, of course,
one of those electrons can be
emitted.
And one of the electrons that
can come off is this p electron
here so that the resulting ion
configuration of the neon atom
is 1s 2 2s 2 2p 5..
But also, this photon can pluck
off this s electron so that the
resulting ion configuration is
1s 2 2s 1 2p 6.
And, of course,
that photon can come in and
pluck off an s electron so that
the resulting ion configuration
here is 1s 2 2s 2 2p 6.
So that one photon,
in principle,
has enough energy to pull off
even the most strongly bound
electron.
And then what we do in this
technique is that we measure the
kinetic energies of these
electrons that are emitted,
and then we plot,
simply, the number of electrons
emitted at a particular energy.
We scan the kinetic energy.
And a typical plot looks like
this.
This is just the number of
electrons coming off with the
particular kinetic energy.
And you see we see three
different kinetic energies.
We see electrons coming off
with 383 eVs,
electrons coming off with 1205
and electrons coming off with
1232 eV.
Well, of course it's going to
turn out here that those
electrons that come off with the
lowest kinetic energy are those
electrons that were most
strongly bound.
There are those electrons that
were in that 1s state.
Why?
Well, look at the energy level
diagram here.
Here are those 1s electrons.
Here is the incident energy of
the photon that we came in with.
If these electrons are most
strongly bound then they're
going to have the highest
ionization energy,
the highest energy to pluck
them off.
And, therefore,
in order to conserve energy,
the incident energy,
the ionization energy plus that
kinetic energy has to equal that
incident energy.
And if this is the largest
energy, well,
then those are the electrons
that are going to have the
lowest kinetic energy.
So those are those 1s
electrons.
That's how we identify those.
And then there are electrons
coming off at 1205 where those
are the electrons from the 2s
state.
That's a little bit higher
energy.
And so if this is the energy of
the incident photon,
it's a photon coming in as the
same energy.
If that's the energy of the
incident photon,
this is then the ionization
energy for those electrons in
that 2s state.
Well, that leftover energy
then, that's the kinetic energy.
And it is a little bit greater
than it was for 1s because,
again, those electrons are less
strongly bound.
And then finally we have this
feature here,
1232 eV.
Those are the 2p electrons.
These electrons are least
strongly bound.
So here is the incident energy
of the photon.
Here is the ionization energy
of those electrons in the 2p
state.
The resulting or the leftover
energy here is the energy that
goes into the kinetic energy of
those electrons,
and that is going to be the
largest kinetic energy --
Because those electrons are
least strongly bound.
So in this neon atom,
we've got three different
states with three different
energies.
That is reflected in the fact
that we're going to have,
in the photoelectron spectrum,
we're going to have three
different kinetic energies for
the electrons coming off.
So by looking at the
photoelectron spectrum you can
immediately tell how many energy
levels you've got.
And, of course,
as the kinetic energy goes up,
well, that means that the
binding energy goes up,
the binding energy gets more
positive meaning the electrons
are less strongly bound.
Or, another way to put it,
as this kinetic energy goes up
this way the binding energy gets
more negative this way.
The electrons are more strongly
bound as that binding energy
gets more negative.
But from this kind of
experiment here we can extract
what these ionization energies
are and we can extract then what
the binding energies are.
Because of conservation of
energy, incident energy of the
photon equals the ionization
energy plus the kinetic energy.
I can rearrange this to
calculate the ionization energy.
I did that for all of these
three features.
Here is the incident energy of
that X-ray photon.
Here is the measured kinetic
energy.
The difference between the two
is the ionization energy.
I solve for that there.
And then that ionization energy
we know is minus the binding
energy.
So if the ionization energy is
21.6 eV, the binding energy here
for that 2p electron is minus
21.6 eV, and for 2s,
minus 48.4 eV,
and 1s, minus 870.2 eV.
I want you to notice how much
more strongly bound that 1s
electron is than the electrons
in the n equals 2 shell,
look at that.
That 1s electron is bound by
870 eV binding energies,
minus 870.
Binding energy for the n equals
2 electrons is minus 48 and
minus 21.
Why is that more strongly
bound?
Well, that electron is in the n
equals 1 shell,
which is much closer to the
nucleus where the attractive
interaction between that
positive charge on the nucleus
and the electron is much
greater.
So this is basically the
technique.
This is how we calculate those
binding energies,
or observe those binding
energies for the electrons in
the multi-electron atom.
What I want to do now is I want
to start on today's lecture.
And you don't have the lecture
notes for today's lecture.
And there is a reason for that.
Oh, and I forgot to tell you to
do something very important.
I'm going to start on today's
lecture.
And through this lecture I am
going to be asking you some
questions.
And you're going to have the
opportunity to answer,
but the way you're going to
have the opportunity to answer
is that you're going to have to
make some paper airplanes.
I will ask a question and then
I will say launch.
And what you have to do is you
have to throw the paper airplane
to the board.
And the first paper airplane
that hits the board from that
section, well,
that section gets a chance to
answer that question.
And we're going to keep score.
And we've got some treats for
the winning section.
The TAs have some scrap paper
and they're going to pass that
out.
And so you can be making some
paper airplanes.
Write the number of your
section on the paper airplane.
Also, some of you are not
strategically located to hit the
blackboard.
If that is the case,
why don't you select somebody
from your recitation to be the
launcher.
They can come down as close as
these few stairs and aim at it
for your section.
Okay?
Okay.
So I am going to start talking.
We're going to talk about the
Periodic Table and the trends in
the properties along the
Periodic Table.
And, of course,
it's the electron
configurations that allow us to
understand the structure of the
Periodic Table.
But it is important to realize
that the Periodic Table was
first assembled by Mendeleev and
other people,
not on the basis of knowledge
of the electron configurations,
but on the basis of knowledge
of the similar properties --
Similar chemical and physical
properties of the elements.
So, for example,
lithium, sodium,
potassium here,
they were all grouped in one
column because they were all
found to be very soft malleable
metals that were very reactive.
Helium, neon,
argon, they were all grouped in
one column because they were
found to be very inert,
very unreactive.
And, of course,
now we understand the electron
configurations,
why these elements have the
similar properties.
In the case of the alkali
metals, lithium,
sodium, potassium,
we've got that extra s
electron, that unpaired electron
that makes those metals very
reactive.
And helium, neon,
argon, we've got an inner gas
shell configuration that makes
those elements very unreactive.
But by the late 1800s and the
early 1900s, the similar
chemical properties of atoms in
a column of a Periodic Table,
that really was strongly
believed, strongly believed to
an extreme.
So, for example,
it was known that human beings
consumed sodium,
salt.
It was known that human beings,
our bodies contained sodium
ions and potassium ions.
Well, if our body has sodium in
it and potassium in it and we
consume those two elements,
why not a little bit of
lithium?
Okay.
About 1925 or so a soft drink
came on the market.
And that soft drink,
they wanted to have a lemony
flavor to that soft drink.
And so, how do you get a lemony
flavor?
Well, you use citric acid.
But citric acid isn't really
soluble in water so,
hey, we've got to make a salt
of the citric acid.
For whatever reason,
a lithium citrate was made.
A lithium salt of citric acid
was made.
And that soft drink was none
other than 7UP.
And, in fact,
if you look here it tells you
that the lithium was touted to
give healthful benefits,
including an abundance of
energy, enthusiasm,
a clear complexion,
lustrous eyes or lustrous hair
and lustrous eyes.
Shinning eyes.
[LAUGHTER] And so this was on
the market until the early 1950s
when finally the anti-psychotic
properties of lithium were being
discovered and the side effects
of lithium were being
discovered.
And the 7UP was then taken off
the market, or at least the
lithium citrate in the 7UP was
removed from the market.
And, of course,
it wasn't until the early 1970s
that lithium was approved as an
anti-psychotic drug,
because it really is poisonous
to the human body in large
amounts.
And so I really don't know how
many individuals had side
effects from drinking 7UP at
that time.
But the moral of the story is
that even though we're about to
talk about some of the general
trends in the Periodic Table,
don't put any element in your
mouth just because it's in the
same column as some element that
you do put in your mouth.
[LAUGHTER] True story.
All right.
One of the properties we're
going to talk about is the
ionization energy.
And we've talked about it
already, but we haven't formally
defined it.
Let me do that here.
Here you see boron with its
electronic structure,
going to boron plus.
The energy change for this
reaction is what we call the
ionization energy.
It's the product minus the
reactants.
That's the ionization energy.
Equivalently,
that ionization energy is minus
the binding energy of the 2p
electron in boron.
This is a process that is
removing the least strongly
bound electron.
When we remove the least
strongly bound electron,
the energy that is required to
do that is called the ionization
energy.
And, more fully,
it's the first ionization
energy.
It is the energy to remove the
electron from this HOAO,
the highest occupied atomic
orbital.
Or, the least strongly bound
electron.
Same idea.
This is the highest occupied
atomic orbital.
Now, generally,
when we say ionization energy
we mean the first ionization
energy.
We often leave out the word
"first".
So whenever you look up an
ionization energy,
implied in that is that it is
the first ionization energy --
The energy to remove the least
strongly bound electron.
The second ionization energy,
well, that is the energy
required to remove another
electron.
But now we're removing it from
boron plus to make boron
plus two.
And, again, we're removing the
next least strongly bound
electron.
That's the second ionization
energy.
Equivalently,
it is minus the binding energy
of the 2s electron in boron
plus.
Not boron.
And then there is a third
ionization energy.
Again, now we're taking boron
plus two, pulling off the next
least strongly bound electron to
make boron plus three.
That's the third ionization
energy.
And we can keep going.
Boron plus three.
Pull out the next electron.
Boron plus four,
that's the forth ionization
energy.
And then the fifth ionization
energy, taking the last electron
off of boron,
boron plus four to make boron
plus five.
That's the fifth ionization
energy.
So these are our definitions
here of the ionization energy.
Now, I'm going to switch to the
side screen.
All right.
But now, here comes the first
question.
I'm going to show you two
reactions here.
The first reaction is a boron
plus going to boron plus two.
We are removing,
here, an s electron.
The second reaction here is
boron going to boron plus.
Again, we are removing a 2s
electron.
And the question is,
are these two energies equal.
In both cases,
we're pulling off an s electron
a 2s electron.
So that's the question.
Now, the way we do this is I'm
going to move to the side,
I'm going to say launch and
then Christine and I will try to
determine the first airplane to
hit the board.
We will pick it up,
and we will ask that recitation
section to answer.
All right.
Ready?
Launch.
Recitation one,
are those energies equal?
Answer?
It can be a group effort.
Hey, you've got a fifty-percent
chance here.
Yes or no?
No.
They're right.
They get a point.
Okay.
You've got to keep score on the
board.
All right.
Now why aren't they equal?
Hey, big no here.
They are not equal because,
in this case,
this is the ionization energy,
the second ionization energy,
as we just defined it.
Boron plus going to
boron plus two,
that's a second ionization
energy.
It's minus the binding energy
of the 2s electron in boron
plus.
Here, this energy,
what this energy is is the
ionization energy of the 2s
electron in boron,
not boron plus.
This is equal to minus the
binding energy of the 2s
electron in boron.
This is minus the binding
energy of the 2s electron in
boron plus.
They're not equal.
The next question is,
which one is greater?
And so, wait a minute.
I'm going to get out of the way
here.
Okay.
Launch.
Recitation nine.
Over there, sorry.
Which one is greater,
top one or bottom one?
Top one.
They are right.
Hey, recitation nine gets a
point.
You can put the score on the
board.
Great.
The top one is greater.
The top one is greater because
the effective charge of this 2s
electron in boron plus is larger
than the effective charge of the
2s electron in boron.
The reason for that is because
in boron plus we have fewer
electrons.
We've got less shielding of the
nucleus by the electrons because
we have fewer electrons.
So that's great.
But this is really very
important for you to understand
here.
This will be on the lecture
notes that I will give to you at
the end of the class.
Because we might run out of
paper, you might want to save
those.
Now we're going to look at the
Periodic Table here.
And I'm going to ask this
following question here.
As we go across the Periodic
Table, what we want to know is
how does the ionization energy
change.
So here is my Periodic Table.
I'm going across this way.
Does the ionization energy
increase or does it decrease?
Now, here is another chance for
you to answer this for your
recitation section.
Launch.
Wads don't count.
[LAUGHTER] Paper airplanes.
Eight.
Where is eight?
Back there.
Hey, okay, eight.
What happens to the ionization
energy as you go across the
Periodic Table?
What?
Increase.
Is that your final answer?
You're right.
All right.
The ionization energy
increases.
Why does that ionization energy
increase?
Here is our example.
Here is our plot.
Ionization energy versus Z as
you go across.
Here is from hydrogen to
helium, that's one row,
it goes up.
Here's from lithium to neon,
another row,
it goes up.
Well, the ionization energy
increases because the nuclear
charge increases.
As you go across the Periodic
Table, the nuclear charge
increases.
The Coulomb interaction
But there is another part to
the Coulomb interaction.
And, of course,
that other part is the
distance.
But as you go across the
Periodic Table,
you're putting electrons into
the same shell,
to the same principle quantum
number shell.
And, in general,
when you put electrons into the
same principle quantum number
shell, you are,
on the average,
the same distance away from the
nucleus.
And so r is the same.
Z is increasing as you go
across.
And so, therefore,
that ionization energy
increases as you go across the
Periodic Table.
Now, however,
you can see that there are some
glitches.
There is a glitch here between
beryllium and boron.
Boron is actually a little bit
lower in ionization energy that
a beryllium.
Can we understand that?
Well, we sure can in terms of
the electronic structure.
So here is the electron
configuration of beryllium,
Z equals 4.
And then here is the electron
configuration of boron,
this is 1s, this is 2p,
Z equals 5.
The bottom line is that it
takes more energy to put the
next electron here into this 2p
state.
And the bottom line is that the
charge on the nucleus does not
increase sufficiently to fully
compensate for the energy that
is necessary to put that next
electron in that higher energy
state.
So this just doesn't get large
enough fast enough to compensate
just for the extra energy that
is needed to put that electron
in the 2p state.
So we have a little glitch
between beryllium and boron.
In addition,
we've got a little glitch right
here between nitrogen and
oxygen.
The oxygen ionization energy is
not as large as you might expect
from the increase in the Z
quantum number.
Again, here's the nitrogen.
Z equals 7, the electron
configuration for nitrogen.
Here it is for oxygen.
And what we had to do for
oxygen is that we had to put
another electron into a 2p
state, a 2p state that already
had an electron in it.
And there is a great deal of
repulsion here between these two
electrons in the same state.
And, again, the Z here,
the nuclear charge did not
increase large enough or greatly
enough to compensate for that
electron-electron repulsion.
And so the ionization energy is
just a little bit lower than it
is for nitrogen.
That same trend,
of course, continues for the
other rows in the Periodic
Table.
Here is the third row.
And there is also a glitch
between magnesium and aluminum.
Magnesium and aluminum are
right below beryllium and boron.
And a glitch between
phosphorous and sulfur,
they're right below nitrogen
and oxygen.
Next question.
As we go down the Periodic
Table what happens to the
ionization energy?
Wait a minute.
I'm getting out of the way.
Okay.
Ready?
Go.
Recitation one.
What happens to the ionization
energy as you go down the
Periodic Table?
Decrease.
Yes, they're right.
Why does it decrease?
It decreases.
As you go down the Periodic
Table, Z is increasing,
that is true,
but as you go down the Periodic
Table you're putting electrons
into shells that,
on the average,
are farther out from the
nucleus.
And so as you go down the
Periodic Table it's that
distance dependence that
dominates the ionization energy.
So across the Periodic Table
ionization energy increases;
down it decreases,
Across it's Z dependence that
dominates because r is constant.
As you go down,
it is the r dependence that
dominates.
That is changing.
Even though Z is changing,
r changes faster than Z.
Great.
Now let's talk about another
property here.
And that other property is
called the electron affinity.
If I take a chlorine atom and I
add an electron to it to make Cl
minus,
the energy change for that
reaction is minus 349 kilojoules
per mole.
That is, the chlorine ion is
more stable than the chlorine
atom.
This is a reaction that
releases some energy.
Now, the question is there is a
quantity called electron
affinity.
You need to define the electron
Are you ready to launch?
All right.
Launch.
Four.
Recitation four.
You're up there,
right?
Can you define the electron
affinity?
What's the electron affinity
equal to?
I am going to write this.
Electron affinity is equal to
what?
Yes?
Answer?
Yes, that's great.
But I want a mathematical
definition here.
EA equals?
Negative IE?
No.
All right.
You've got to do another
launch.
Ready?
Launch.
Recitation one.
What is the electron affinity
equal to?
Answer?
Beep.
What it is?
No.
Next launch.
Ready?
Launch.
What is it?
Nine.
What is the answer?
What is the electron affinity
equal to?
Beep.
What?
Yes.
Keep going.
Not ionization energy.
Okay.
The electron affinity here is
minus this energy,
right?
If you add an electron to an
atom there is an energy change.
The electron affinity is
defined as minus that energy
change.
Okay.
Great game.
We didn't get very far.
However, from these scores,
recitation section one does
win.
Okay.
I will see you on Monday.